foreign
by day I'm a police Lieutenant with the
Winthrop Massachusetts police department
and psychotherapist at night
people might be shocked that a police
officer is advocating for psychedelics
but I believe we're in the middle of a
mental health crisis across the whole
country
I want to bring psychedelic assisted
Psychotherapy to the police because in
policing PTSD is a big problem
[Music]
there's a lot of uncertainty with this
type of work you don't know what kind of
a call is going to come in
any time an officer is waking up to go
to work their their nervous system is
activating in a really distinct kind of
way
you're not going in calm you're tensed
up you're jacked up a little bit you
have a little bit of cortisol and
adrenaline going through your
bloodstream and that's a daily
occurrence
over time over time over the course of
an entire career it can cause problems
foreign
escalation of death by suicide in
officers the numbers related to
depression the numbers related to
suicidality anxiety they're staggering
your past and your training and
experience go into the way that you act
on the street
trauma tends to narrow people's
perspective trauma Taps into
fundamental fear responses it creates an
Us and Them perspective
we're in a point in history right now
where
that needs to change
it's really important for us to not have
a knee on the throat of a civilian
we need to get together we need to take
walls down and I think that medications
like MDMA will be able to help with that
because it'll temper down that fear
response it'll bring in New Perspective
or widen perspective to allow for ideas
around
being one group one family
my MDMA experience was federally
sanctioned a part of a research protocol
when the medicine took effect
I had this deep overwhelming sense of
love
come across me
but what happened
right after
that sense of love was a sense of
gratitude and it gave me the needed
perspective as to how MDMA is going to
help somebody that's struggling with
treatment resistant severe PTSD
our officers will make decisions better
if they are rested if they are well if
their resiliency is at the highest
capacity
I care about helping with that
because I'm helping not only the
officers
but that person that intersects with
them in that moment
where that decision might have to be
made
and maybe the best possible decision
will be made
we're on a precipice of a sea change in
the way we help people
we need to destigmatize access
we need to speed up access we need to
get enough therapists trained because
when used carefully cautiously with care
and guidance under certain protocols
I think these medicines can be very very
effective and helpful in people dealing
with their suffering
so I mean that's pretty bold right I
made a police officer advocating the use
of it currently the schedule one
substance uh what do you guys think
about what you just heard
I think that it's